A person who is a Muslim who fears Allah
will not talk about.
>> What do you mean bro? Of course you have
to speak about this an evil that's done
to children and kids. What are you
talking about? The prophet said lowest
form of iman is to move a harmful object
from the road.
>> I want to invite you to add something
powerful to your jar list.
>> We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly.
>> Just imagine this. You help someone
learn with how to pray,
>> how to recite surah faty,
>> every
prayer for the rest of their lives,
>> you share in a reward.
>> When they teach their children
>> and their children's children,
>> the reward continues for you. For just
£100,
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people like
you. Learn salah. Donate today and earn
rewards that never stop.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends
never ever disappoints us. He never
fails to disappoint us. You would have
think it would not get worse with him
mocking the whole boycott movement, you
know, drink cola and McDonald's and this
and that and whatever it is for that
matter, you know, belittling the matter,
uh, supporting Zionist with all due
respect. I mean, that's what it in a
nutshell. the massacre, the genocide
that's happening. Um, you know, it's all
calm, it's all casual. You think it
wouldn't get worse? Well, it does. Here
in this video, he's talking about the
Epstein files. Yeah. And in the Epstein
files, Subhan Allah. Like, it's
unbelievable. These are people who would
bring these children. There's rumors of
them sacrificing them. There's rumors of
them eating them. There's rumors.
There's stuff that's showing that they
were them. like this is this is vile and
disgusting on the highest degree. Yes,
they're worshiping God bad or whatever
is for that matter. Here is what he had
to say. Yeah, this is you cannot y I
don't think you're going to be shocked.
I don't think you're going to be shocked
when you see this. Here's the first clip
of what he had to say. Unbelievable.
>> A person who is a Muslim who fears Allah
will not talk about.
>> So now this is where it gets
problematic. Even if he is in the files,
he's done these acts of to girls,
graping, sacrificing,
all this kind of stuff. You still need
to obey him. I I see deep hypocrisy here
and I am very careful to what I'm about
to say and I'm and I have no choice but
to say this. So, if it was your children
in those files and they were doing that
to your innocent children, may Allah
protect them, you still obey the rule.
Yeah.
Let's we need to make this practical now
because you said we have to still obey
them. This is where we need to ask you
this question. If your children your
children were on that island and then
and they've done this heinous acts on
your children, would you still obey the
ruler? Answer this question. I want you
to you have to answer this question,
bro. You have to answer this question
because you've got become you've become
so vile. Yes. So vile and I'm talking to
parent. This not backbiting. This is
vile. You're telling me that if this if
this is even fs and fs that they're
doing this to girls or boys whatever it
says you know this is the hypocrisy this
is where you don't love your brothers
what you love for yourself because if
it's your children bro you you know you
will you will you will rip people apart
but it's so easy said when you're saying
if even even if they are even if they
are so even if they are yes not that
we're saying they are we're saying this
there's no evidence Islamically good
okay I mean I agree with you on that but
you're saying even if they are yes you
you you obey them okay answer me a
simple question you have to answer
you're going to watch this video if this
was your children and they were doing
this to your children these evil vile
acts to your children would you still
obey would you still obey the ruler
nobody's asking by the way I'm against
I'm I follow the theology that we should
not rebel against the ruler yes but you
are now taking it to levels where you're
like yo yeah and this not the this not
from sorry to to come and tell me that
are going to notice and say obey that
ruler in this in this in this matter
you're out of your bloody mind bro you
you are crazy how about that you are
crazy bro are you are you okay little
children let's carry on let's break
going to break it down for attention
let's see files.
>> Should we still obey the ruler if he has
been in the Epstein files?
These files
you read something online is the Quran.
Okay. Number one, why are you laughing?
It's not a laughing matter. Do you get
it? I don't Why is he laughing? That
weird laugh like as if and he's the way
he laughs as if he's like, "Yeah, you
know, if there was a ruler in there,
yeah, you know, maybe we should ignore
that as well." I don't I don't know if
he's going to say that. I wouldn't be
surprised if he does. Now he's true and
let's be honest here we can't this is
why it's important for me talking about
being just speaking truth against even
if it's myself just because I have a
dislike to him against for the sake of
Allah nothing personal and you guys know
I don't fall I I abstain from him to
backbit and calling names okay that's
why I'm calling these names that people
call him and call him a rabbi or
whatever for I believe that's not
correct here subhan Allah he's right in
the sense where if I'm going to be
speaking about speak the truth even if
it's against myself he's right if a if
an evildoer comes and gives you a a news
that's true you have to verify that
He does have a point there. We can't
come and say um that oh I heard from
this person. He's right with all
respect. With all due respect he is
right. But let's see what else he has to
say.
You're Muslims you talk you think like
that. Anybody who gives you any piece of
news. Oh look he's in the Epstein files.
Oh my god. So true. This is and this has
no
you like sheep. Allah sheep. sheep for
the kufur.
Sheep like for the kufur.
>> I'm so sorry. Um if there's anyone
that's a sheep for the kufur
um you know it's it's um yourself.
That's all I'm going to say. If there's
anyone that's a shear, it's yourself. Uh
so again I said I agree that we cannot
come and say just because there are
certain pictures or etc in the shar it
doesn't work like that. There has to be
solidified evidence that the Shia has
made it clear
talks about in his Islamic Jewish
prudence what those criterias are
unknown person comes online gives you
something he's in the Epstein he's in
the Epstein no he is it's true it's true
the evidence are there it's
Epstein files
>> well we can't say it's we can't say it's
Bkari neither can we say that there is
no truths in there per say for certain
things. Obviously when it comes to the
honor of a Muslim we have to be very
careful very careful 100%. But we cannot
come and say there are absolute ultimate
false. Do you get it? Like to say that's
absolute false is a different issue.
What the Sharia requires to enact a
punishment or say this is this person
has done that is a whole different
category. That's number one. Number two
give you that benefit for for debate
sake. Yes. Still you have to you still
have to obey him. You still have to obey
him.
>> So, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. What? What
does he mean by I'm a bit confused now.
What do you mean he you have to? Cuz I
didn't understand. I don't know who he's
talking to. You still need to obey him
on what? You still need to obey him on
what? I'm trying to understand it. Which
I I haven't understood. I'll be clever.
What do you mean? He still obey what?
You still obey the ruler on what? He
hasn't given clarity. What? If he's in
the files, if um there was just a
picture of him. I need to understand
what you mean by that. We still obey
him. On what basis? I hope he clarifies.
I'm trying to understand. What's he
talking about?
>> It's FBI verified. Mashallah. FBI
verified.
Have mercy on yourself. Have mercy on
yourself. Allah.
FBI verified.
FBI verbih
FBI
since when do we take the narration of
kufur
in such a way?
>> Well, well that's true. FBI is not our
source of uh evidence within is right on
that is right on. Let's be let's be
that's his right. We're going to go FBI.
Yeah. Okay.
>> Just let me let me understand this. Let
me understand this. You you as a Muslim
taking news about your brother from the
enemy and believing it.
Does that sound logical to you?
Didn't it occur to you that they're
lying
or it's not true or they're trying to do
something about us?
>> Well, sorry. Your brothers and sisters
have been telling you that the boycott,
boycott, boycott. Yes. And they were
telling you it works. You like, "Oh, no.
How is it going to work? It doesn't
work." Blah, blah, blah. This that
what's it going to do? It does. Did you
take it uh when it came to your brother
and sisters telling you that? No, you
didn't. But let's carry on.
>> Trying to cause damage, harm us. What
benefit is that? He's in the Epstein
files. I know all of them. I don't. A
person who is a Muslim who fears Allah
will not talk about.
>> What do you mean? But of course you have
to speak about this. An evil that's done
to children and kids. What are you
talking about? The prophet said lowest
form of iman is to move a harmful object
from the road. How are you going to tell
me if there's people have abused
children etc that we should not talk
about? Are you okay? What are you
talking about? Okay. Well, are you okay?
>> You going talking about the Epstein
files? You have you have you have a
Naruto profile picture, right? Is that
you?
>> What? What are you talking about Naruto?
I don't give I don't give Pikachu on.
It's the huck is the huck. What are you
talking? I don't give I don't know if he
has teddy tubbies on. What does him
having teletubbies got to do with
speaking the huck? If you go to a Sharia
and Sharia judge and they say this man
saw a crime happen. Oh but he has he
watches tubbies. He's got t-sh on. He's
got to prophet Shar say I don't care
what he has brother tell is he is he
reliable. He's got is he sane? Does he
mean he's an adult? Did he see the
witness? Is he reliable? I don't care if
you watch Terry Tabies or Narita or
whatever that that is called. I don't
understand what's going to do with it.
If anything, you'll be rejected, you
know, with your bias, you know, and and
bias. You be rejected in Sharia. So,
sisters, nothing else need said. Faris
never fails to disappoint us. And that's
it. That's what where else can we say we
are fasting. May Allah protect us.
That's all I'm going to say. Sisters,
don't forget to support our brother and
sisters. This is the new in town. We are
printing mass in Italian, German,
French, Spanish, Japanese, and English.
70,000 mats, 20,000 for children, 50,000
adults. Your donation don't just go to
the mats, it goes towards onetoone salah
instructors, the salah mats, the salah
pro app that's been downloaded by 50,000
people and being used as for you with
diversifying,
the salah pro hubs, the salah pro
studios, the provin. May Allah bless and
preserve you guys. Go to the link and
donate now.
Betto.